hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Bob taking a mud
bath the series Oh Oh Bob is pampering
himself but I really love his expression
down in the corner he is oh so
uncomfortable and very sad about his
life but Lisa's having OH
wrote down an idea for momentum
conserver
o8 momentum conserver Oh Oh God
oh I think he might be falling asleep in
the tub which probably bathroom way did
you just say stinky you go to bed you go
to bed little buddy you'll work on your
rocketship and you'll go to the moon
tomorrow don't worry about a thing you
just dream your dreams oh what a good
that didn't help Bob at all he's still
very very very dirty we're gonna sleep
Bob just just sleep everyone I sleep
everybody gonna sleep damn it don't even
bother to get under the covers because
there's no covers to get under it feels
so bad I was just flirting with everyone
in the Bob and Wade were just being
dirty working on they're probably gonna
kill them explosion spaceship
hi Wade where are you up Wade Huambo oh
wait wait don't eat that wait don't eat
that Wade oh my god Wade Wade where did
you put that what did you do no don't
eat that
Wade uh-oh it's good apparently it's
only been sitting up for a while now
Wade you are so insane this way we're
trying to sleep Wade what's really funny
is that I can actually picture this
actually happening even though in the
real world that never would I can still
picture we'd love sleeping just talking
to himself over and over and eating a
very old bowl of cereal Oh Wade I have
no hopes for your future in this game
keep eating wow that was a long gap in
between the bites that must
be the world soggies bowl of cereal oh
no he has to go to the bathroom hmm
I think this Wade's gonna live in
perpetual discomfort because I don't
think it was actually gonna do anything
for himself again another bite of cereal
this is going wonderfully for you life
is just a bowl cereal okay thanks
Bob's gonna wake up and wonder where his
bowl of cereal one you gonna do
something you're gonna go to the
bathroom you can think about going to
there you go you're gonna go to the
bathroom all right good job buddy
yeah and cancel the bath sorry buddy I
gotta leave you uncomfortable you're
gonna go to work and make everyone
really really care to join him as your
Marco look care to join him I didn't
know that I can join people in their
work oh whoa I didn't know this at all I
would have had us all work on the same
job but that would have been good
because then we would be competing we
could all be horrible scientists I mean
we could still do that we can change it
up and go scientists welcome dr. EEP Lee
heir to a vital and rewarding career in
the field of medicine being new to the
job take some time to get familiarized
with the location I don't know what I
don't know what it how do i I don't know
what I don't know what I'm not sure what
I do here to default Japan Ave wash
hands to sterilize germs greet to
coworkers chat with the patient this
doesn't seem like things that a doctor
would be supposed to ok go raid the food
okay that's exactly what I'm gonna do I
guess free food at work oh this is
exciting not really but I did not know
that this was in addition here
ah there we go now I'm happy I guess I
can go talk with patients even though
I'm incredibly unqualified treat bloaty
head with a shot again I don't think I
should be quite I just started I haven't
even been to med school I don't know I
have no idea what I'm supposed to be
doing okay you want some food
don't lie to me as I just stare at you
for a bit oh no are you feeling bad I
used my black magic too big to plate go
away well okay I I hope that was good
for you now excuse me I need to do my
little body dance that's totally
inappropriate to be doing here and now
but goodbye okay good job face is cured
I think alrighty then
where am I supposed to go there's the
bathroom well then I'll just use that
anyway I was one of my objectives was
not to treat a pet I was not supposed to
do that
it's not supposed to do that the dudes
oh the dance others hilarious I feel so
happy on this toilet now let me actually
chat with the patient and hopefully I be
fine excuse me I need to introduce
myself to you because I got nothing
better to do with my life oh no you'll
come to me Oh God lag I know I always
get crowds around me cuz I'm so handsome
excuse all of your needs to be cured in
whatever but I'm just gonna do these
things there we go
okay I got everything I needed now I'm
gonna go have a cup of coffee because
that's what people do I don't know why
you know I love the sins I will openly
admit that I love the sins but I also
don't know why the Sims are so appealing
why is it so fun to watch people live
fake lives
I mean are our lives fake because we're
not taking full advantage of them man it
would be so much easier to live life you
could just set yourself to a task and it
would automatically happen but that's
not how life works and that's why we
like it man that guy is getting swamped
I am so sorry sir
but I'm gonna have to talk with you a
spoiled latest episode
alright I'll do that in an energized
fashion club hello hello sorry sorry for
spoiling that I'm not tell
not-safe-for-work joke in front of the
children don't mind me guys oh my god
trick with Han buzzer hey you're
probably dying from an incurable disease
but let me get this for you
she's hey he liked it homonym I'm gonna
mess with you even more give fake bad
news in a hospital oh I'm the best
doctor ever oh no you're gonna die me
I think I'm giving this guy advice that
he's gonna die
same time she's getting this news okay
well that's sad
I'll just put you in a bed and hopefully
if I kick someone else out of it I'm I'm
I did a thing Natalie ten thousand
dollars welcome to America okay goodbye
sir have fun being in bankruptcy for
your cure disease social commentary on
the American Health System excuse me I'm
gonna stop treating you real quick and
I'm gonna mop okay never mind then I'm
not gonna mop this bottle I'm gonna go
home and then see Bob and Wade and then
have a good time back there that was
weird I've never done that before I also
bought all the expansion's with Cup
cause a lot of money but oh no one's
home yet okay don't mind me just gonna
do push-ups in the middle of a field
here while I'm waiting for my friends to
go home rummage in the tree I'm a
glutton
huh I didn't know that I was a glutton I
thought I was a glutton for punishment
but I didn't know that I was glutton
okay all right then taking a bath being
naked very proud of my nakedness look at
me is this what you wanted Internet is
this what you wanted okay I'm gonna
clean up this cereal I'm doing hardcore
let's play commentary right now I'm
cleaning up the cereal I'm us I'm
scrubbing it in the in the sink and I
think that's advantageous because
the only sink in the apartment and
frankly I I think I should also probably
brush my teeth just as a general health
thing you should probably brush your
teeth twice a day that's very important
in your daily life because you want to
make sure that your teeth last long
did you know actually that the only
reason that teeth rot in this day and
age is because if the diet that we have
high in sugar and stuff like that it
causes teeth to rot much much much more
rapidly they actually observe this um
nomadic tribe in some country that had
not had a lot of contact with you know
the civilized world and especially the
civilized world's I'd and once they
switch to the new man's diet their teeth
just start rotting real bad and that's
because of the diet that we have and as
you can see now I'm sitting on sitting
on Wade's bed
doing something with that food there and
I'm bmd being real cool things actually
Bob's bed if I didn't say that Nam
Wade's bed I think I might have said
Wade's bed boys dating a while for my
friends you come home this is what I
usually do when I'm home alone just sit
sad alone on a bed eating cereal waiting
for anybody to come stop me from being a
horrible glutton I really am I'm a slob
when I'm alone it's only when other
people are around that I feel
responsible to actually take care of
myself wait wait wait whoa whoa whoa hey
wait a minute there what oh god wait
don't interrupt me okay and wait whoa
hey whoa hey whoa whoa whoa well I'm
gonna scum spurt okay there I am now oh
hi
have you ever seen me I'm gonna cheer
you up because I don't even okay well
alright then okay thank you all right
I'm gonna cheer you up it's gonna be
good school
it's okay total stranger you're gonna be
all right
cuz I'm markiplier oh well thank you
thank you how about show off my muscles
have you ever seen my muscles my muscles
are pretty cool have you ever seen him
si si yeh see you want to give him a
squeeze oh okay
my charisma let go this is not work
Samba yobs uh-huh
crazy scheme oh oh oh but I'm so
confident and now I'm angry come on
insult face I'm gonna insult your face
I'm gonna insult your stupid face
you better not insult my feet oh that's
so mean
alright fine fine balmy day good bye
I didn't need you anyway I didn't even
want to know you ahh
markiplier I don't need your approval
yeah waited leave in my bed
Oh Wade's gonna get it now Oh got a
goodbye okay weights gonna get it now
I'm gonna take all of my aggression out
on you Wade
Wade Wade I need to rant and rave need
ranting rave to somebody brush
did you wallet sharp Sousa alright I'm
really gonna try to find common ground
with wait here Nader someone trying to
be his friend I will try smell smell 'no
smell no no owner
see how about friendly sharp share
brilliant ideas oh ah given that weight
is completely insane my crazy ideas
probably seem rational let's see it was
your day Wade I am interested in you as
person even though you're only thinking
about yourself as I know Wade is want to
do I believe that we could be friends
also check out my bro hey Bob Wow Bob
got a lot of money compared to all of
what we did
hey I think we made a lot of good
progress over here hi Bob
Bob Bob Bob were the best of friends now
well maybe not but uh who hey uh whose
other who's there
hey wait wait come back here come back I
need to say hi wait whoa hey I didn't
ask you to come in the house but
alrighty then we'd go work on the
rocking ship rock rock broccoli rocket
by ship oh hello
why are you sitting on Wade's bed you
don't know what's been on Wade's bed why
would you just sit there excuse me I
need to go talk to Elise live Levesque
oh she's a teenager
nevermind now and he does to leave yeah
I thought she was an adult never mind
then please get out very quickly I don't
know why you decided to run into my
house but this just got very weird so
please get out goodbye goodbye goodbye
[ __ ] that lady am i right yeah
rage run on the trim rage run I want a
rage run on a treadmill
Oh so on a rage run on a treadmill
there we go treadmill fit step treadmill
okay we'll just put this in doubt side
that's where it should be I don't know
how it's gonna get power but I'm gonna
rage run on a treadmill whoo bar rage
filled run okay excuse me I'm gonna do a
thing wait shut up
I have to go rage run yeah never mind
not talking to her either
wow that was quick on the sweat I don't
even look all that angry I look sweet as
ever
Wade build what are you doing wait wait
no no Wade that's my bad damn it Wade
hello hi ladies hi how's it going hey
how's it going there cherish you're
obviously not a teenager that's okay
ask risk a question sure
how's it going there this isn't weird at
all oh I smell yeah yeah gobble and your
appearance hey I know I look bad but
that don't matter
bye Bob were you waking woken by a
disturbance in the force ba I don't know
if I should be very Bob why are you why
you were just sleeping Bob
oh there bob goes okay sorry just my bad
smell bother you you're embarrassed by
what embarrassed by my romantic nature
I'm gonna use a pickup light on you yeah
yeah what come on now all right fine
whatever
goodbye this has been a weird day a
really weird day
embarrassed Oh awkward encounter that
was barely awkward at all
well it's kind of awkward but whatever
good night hey achievement introvert Oh
half a sin do nothing social for 24
hours
yay that's like the story of my life oh
boy
I actually haven't left my house in a
long time so that's the end of this
episode so thank you everybody so much
for watching I really hope you're
enjoying the Sims
I know I am it's really weird but
somehow a direct analog for my life so
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you
and the next video bye bye see what you
can do with your stick arms in your big
butt and your chicken Eliza call me
Maggie no
anyways